the plane was flying low and due to land
when it came down in the tourist town of
Bukhara rescue workers raced to the
scene finding parts of the wreckage on
fire local people joined officials to
search for bodies and survivors
the incident was very tragic the full
force of the Nepal Army and the police
have been deployed for rescue operations
the yeti Airlines flight from Kathmandu
was full of passengers 15 of them were
foreign Nationals footage posted on
social media shows the flight's final
moments the twin Pro ATR appears to make
a sharp turn before coming down
bystanders captured footage of flames
rising from the wreckage the yeti
Airlines aircraft was reportedly 15
years old and equipped with an old
transponder with unreliable data
we looked and then just managed to look
at the records of data received by flat
tracking websites on the aircraft and
it's been showing on that particular has
been showing some strange data that has
been sent from the aircraft the altitude
flat tweeting up and down very very
uh large fluctuations that that doesn't
make sense so
um
again this is very early days poor
maintenance and lack standards have led
to several fatal accidents in Nepal in
recent years
flying can be challenging Nepal has some
of the world's most remote runways
surrounded by mountains they can be
difficult for Pilots to land in
this is the worst plane crash since 2018
when 51 people were killed when a flight
from Bangladesh crashed on Landing in
Kathmandu an investigation into the
cause of this one is underway assadbag
Al Jazeera
of ramyata limbu has more from the
capital Kathmandu
the
Nepal because of our topography our
difficult geography there have been
numerous crashes or accidents pain
crashes in the past but normally usually
in Mountain areas and where you have the
stall or small Mountain aircrafts that
fly normally due to poor visibility and
because of the difficult difficult
terrain but today
it's the weather is good there's good
visibility
so people are wondering uh what happened
I did speak to some people within the
airline industry and of course the
company but at this moment they say it's
really difficult to gauge or say what uh
exactly happened but because it was in
the town of Pokhara around where there
were there's an army base police
administrative bases around relief and
rescue operations happened I think
quickly
um the Prime Minister himself has
directed the civil aviation authority of
Nepal to facilitate rescue and relief
operations as fast as possible and a
call center and as
decided that a whole Center should be
established at the airport so that
relatives of those pathogens involved in
the crash can get more details and
updates of what's Happening
well let's now speak to Sean maffet an
aviation analyst he joins us live from
gloucestershire in the UK thank you for
being on Al Jazeera look I know it's uh
obviously very early on and there will
be many investigations to come but is
there any early indication as to why
this plane might have crashed
well it's very odd um it's it doesn't
look a very likely thing to be happening
um it does appear though that the
aircraft
stalled and that's the aviation term for
when you lose lift from the wings and
usually you lose one Wing before the
other which is what seems to have
happened here the aircraft was pointing
upwards and then One Wing the left wing
drops and it then spirals into the
ground which suggests that the left wing
had indeed stalled that's to say the
aviation term for running out of lift
when it's not got enough airflow over
the wing surface so can you just explain
uh what could potentially cause a stall
well
no I can't I mean I could explain in
general but I certainly couldn't explain
why that happened here
um a basic part of training for all
Pilots to be able to cope with stalls
and to recover from them
um and particularly not to get into a
stalled condition in the first place so
we don't know how that happened
um and by the time they were trying to
recover it was already too late right
well what do you know about Yeti
Airlines what sort of safety record uh
does it have
well as an individual Airline not too
bad
um that they actually recently only had
five aircraft now they've only got four
so they're not a very big Airline but in
general terms
um Nepali uh airlines are not thought of
uh globally as being particularly safe
in fact no Airline from Nepal is allowed
to fly into the European Union because
of their safety record right well how
safe is this particular aircraft the ATR
72 and how widely how popular is it
around the world
well they first flew in 1988 built in
France
um ATR stands for Avion de transport
Regional
um and the 72 in the in the title ATR 72
reflects the number of passengers that
it can carry it actually had 68 on this
occasion plus four crew
um
it's a a popular airplane there are a
thousand of them flying around the world
um it's not thought of as being
particularly unsafe except perhaps for
the fact that they it does tend to fly
in some areas where safety is not quite
as high as others I mean Nepal is a very
mountainous region and flying in
mountainous regions is more risky than
um flying elsewhere so uh possibly that
has some uh reflection on it
I guess on there what can you tell us
about flying in the area and the
conditions at the time of the crash do
you think that that could have played a
part at all obviously the geography of
Nepal makes for pretty challenging
flying at times
indeed although the weather looked to be
quite good at the time
um I think it might be relevant that
um this is a brand new airport
um as I think you said it only opened uh
two weeks before on the 1st of January
so it's possible that the crew were not
as familiar well presumably it's the
first time they'd flown in there I don't
know that but it quite seems quite
likely
um so that may have had something to do
with it although I do have to say that
for any pilot who's flying to an airport
that they've never flown to before they
will do a lot of study beforehand
um to find out all about it there is one
thing at the moment there are
unconfirmed reports
um that they were Landing they were
trying to land on the opposite direction
to what they'd been cleared to do now
this is entirely unconfirmed reports
this is on from from Twitter
um in the local area okay no doubt we
will um clarify those in the days and
weeks ahead thank you so much that is
Sean muffin Aviation analyst from the UK
thank you